[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec un sommaire très complet puisqu'on
va parler évidemment de la fête grille
vous on va parler aussi de la connerie
c'est ce que s'est dit cette affaire ou
pas où on va parler peut-être aussi des
césars et pourra parler florence mercadé
ou soit bon sens patrice d'avocate au
barreau de versailles côtés de pierre
chevalier
bonsoir vous êtes species de la
communication des ménages aux qui
s'appelle night watch knights les
chevaliers en anglais c'est pas night
comme la nuit un nom alors c'est la
guerre la garde de nuit pour connaître
michael lumbroso bonjour et merci se
montre avec 12 est chirurgien dentiste à
versailles et jean charles lajoie denis
vous êtes éditeur toujours toujours
toujours pas changé de vie n'en voulez
pas changer
non mais celui des choses qu'on parle
tout de suite de sa venir de jurés oui
parce que ça c'est eric bertin denis
ouais là son premier livre non c'est son
deuxième troisième livre c'est le
premier chez nous et c'est une histoire
à ses dires de jurer ça interpelle les
avocats ça bah ça devrait ça devrait s'y
sont pas en grève pour les défendre
éventuellement annoncé le jury c'est
l'histoire de
de théron réalité cette ville hier de
terroristes qui décide un beau jour de
d'enlever sept capitaines d'industrie à
travers le monde pour les juger contre
crimes contre l'humanité et crime
écologique etc et donc ils vont les
juger devant c'est tenir de mesurer sur
internet et bien évidemment ils n'ont
plus l'intention j'ai envie
contrefoutent de la vie des sept
milliards de jurés ils ont bien
évidemment l'intention de les exécuter
et il ya un policier qui n'est pas loin
de partager leurs thèses en disant oui
effectivement ils ont enlevé 7 salopards
mais quand même moi je suis légaliste
fut policiers et s'est essayé à la loi
droit supérieur voilà et de perdre toute
l'originalité du roman outre l'intrigué
vraiment astucieuse intelligent c'est la
personnalité du policier qui bataille
sans arrêt entre cette certaine
sympathie qu'il a pour les thèses
défendues par ces terroristes et et la
défense de la loi et de la haie de
l'ordre voilà donc là c'est très très
bien on est ce qu'on est perçue d'apps
et de la grêle des avocats et avocates
aux grèves ici ne sont pas tous en grève
au 3 mètres mais reconnais là donc c'est
une granulométrie ma part tant
qu'avocate
il faut recadrer un peu nous sont là on
fait la grève du judiciaire oui on fait
la grève des audiences
d'accord d'accord mais pendant ce temps
là vous gagnez quand même de l'argent
donc bien il ya déjà des cabinets qui
gagnent plus rien d'accord tout business
toute la finance vous faites toujours
mais pas vous mais en règle générale si
on a des consultations au golan les
consultations qui naissait la grève du
lait d'ici
c'est la grève du judiciaire dont est
donc celle aux grèves hockey a non pas
du tout tranquille qu'est donné qu'ils
ne sont que du jubilaire pour cela mais
pour les autres c'est une grève
je pense que pour les ados bien 100% de
barreaux les rêves
non mais c'est vrai on est pas on n'est
pas une profession qui a dans l'adn la
volonté de faire mes rêves
donc ça ne vous arrive jamais de faire
grimper donc si on le fait est que 100%
des barreaux le fond c'est qu'il ya
quand même une bonne news de quitte à
avoir des baisses de chiffre d'affaires
il ya des cabinets qui touche plus rien
parce qu'il ya plus d'être y avait
maintenant on est revenu sûr d'être
juridictionnelle des commissions
d'office la défense des libertés
ça c'est reparti en revanche toutes les
audiences de fonds sont effectivement
renvoyé et on a des très très bonne
raison pour le faire
mais les causes de votre colère sont
tout à fait légitime mais je reviens
juste ce que vous venez d environ 600 %
des barreaux sont conséquents sénat la
majorité n'a jamais sonné mais pas nous
arrêter là sa liste prédéfinie zine et
idées mais l'unanimité ne fait jamais
raison enfin je raccroche je rappellerai
que 98 % des allemands et des
autrichiens en beauté hitler est-ce
qu'ils avaient raison je suis pas sûr
pour son enfant
morceau gagner mais je dis arrêtons avec
ces sept jours ce truc-là narimène
invités non mais c'est fou la gamme et
en colère les week-ends ambrose a
justement vu les des professions
médicales aussi sont affectées par cette
réalité sur les dentistes en particulier
on a une caisse autonome qui a anticipé
une pénurie démographique depuis 20 ans
donc à titre personnel je cotise très
fortement depuis 20 ans notre caisse a
mis de côté une réserve qui va du coup
être spoliés par la réforme ce qui est
tout à fait inacceptable
et puis ici je lui encore plus loin mais
on a une réforme on est une réforme bien
très peu de temps avec la fameuse le
fameux 100% santé on s'est vus plafonné
sur certains de nos honoraires de
prothèses ski complètement aberrant
c'est comme si par exemple on décrétait
du jour au lendemain que deux bouteilles
de vin
quel que soit le vin sa cote à plus de
50 euros c'est quand même aberrant de
venir plafonné
quelque chose qui est finalement il ya
une libre concurrence aussi bon pour la
santé mais qu'en fait c'est tout un
modèle de ces réactions libéral pour moi
aujourd'hui complètement remis en
question et il ya plus de libéral que le
mot canessa justement l'atteinte aux
professions libérales
parce que c'est vrai qu'on voit de plus
en plus les gars l'assurance par exemple
québec plafonner les dictionnaires ça
c'est tout ça toujours été comme ça d'un
dictionnaire
donc ça toujours été plafonnées ça fait
vingt ans que ça n'a pas été revu malgré
nos demandes depuis 20 ans disant il
faut quand même revoir un très bon mais
ça les honoraires libres c'est une chose
mais n'ont pas digéré
mais bon les réformes sont si souvent un
peu vite promulguée mal fichu là ils
viennent de se rendre compte que
finalement les mutuelles ont trouvé des
moyens des subterfuges de ne pas
rembourser à 100% je le vois tous les
jours dans mon cabinet les patients
finalement non pas les remboursements
qui était promis escompté alors que les
cotisations ont augmenté et que
maintenant le ministère de la santé dit
oui on va essayer de voir comment
minimiser l'augmentation des cotisations
de mutuelle finalement tout est fait un
peu en dessus dessous en tout cas trop
vite mais la preuve le premier projet de
réforme avait exclu les professions
libérales et c'est de l'eau voix qui a
été qui a remis les professions
libérales donne en disant bon bras
dessous c'est universel donc c'est pour
tout le monde on met les professions
libérales
donc ce qui est quand même ils
s'aperçoivent aujourd'hui qu'ils
auraient mieux fait pas le faire oui
mais ça permet de le financer ils
peuvent récupérer entre 8 et 10
milliards finalement
la manne assurance pour tout dire je
vous demande si c'est vraiment qu'ils
sont financières aussi une espèce de ce
qu'ils demandent enfin le mal français
cette fois on trouve toujours une
corporation kahlaoui c'est honteux c'est
scandaleux bien général ne doit pas
prendre le pas sur son bien personnel
non mais on n'est pas un régime spécial
puisque on a les limites d'âge les 64
ans pour s'appliquer pour nous les malus
bonus vont s'appliquer pour nous la
seule chose c'est qu'on finance de
manière autonome nos retraites points
donc est-ce que je n'ai pas déficitaire
bénéficier je veux qu'elle soit 20
millions d'euros oui c'est qu'il y avait
là je sais mon cas je voudrais encore
une fois se trouve la justice que tu ne
trouve pas très sain de la part
d'avocats de laisser des gens en prison
disent on veut nous fait grève et je
trie problème l'avocat l'unanimité des
barreaux dont vous parlez ferait bien de
s'occuper de la présomption d'innocence
qui est bafouée dans nos sociétés depuis
des années de plus en plus présente pas
beaucoup ça veut dire à peine à porter
jeter sa robe se coucher par terre pour
brûler des cas civile bruit des débats
bruna code pénal ça n'est pas parce que
les invocations grève en votant grève
sur la question des retraites que 10
pour autant il abandonne tout leur
président mais il ya d'autres combats et
je trouve que dieu fait beaucoup de
bruit à chaque fois qu'il ya clients à
qui elle a confié quelques parts il ya
quelqu'un guidée au il ya d'autres
combats qu'ils avaient toujours d'autres
droit d'avoir un avis mais si on
continuer à exercer notre métier
normalement notre grève
ce serait quoi c'est justement un
brassard et puis on continue à bosser et
on n'aurait rien on aurait bien sûr n'en
est rien passé sont préservés puisque
nous défendrons les libertés et les
problématiques d'emprisonnement d'accord
tout le monde reste en prison en plein
sur l'évolution des mises en liberté des
femmes en trop mauvaise foi passe à
l'événement l'événement c'est donc la
sphère griveaux et c'est donc
l'événement eboy tout le monde ne parle
que de ça évidemment alors la sphère
griveaux et ses conséquences et ce
qu'ils aient besoin de rappeler les
faits toujours les connais je crois donc
c'est la diffusion d'une d'une sextape
privé sur sur les réseaux sociaux et
voilà qui mettait en cause le candidat à
la mairie de paris et il a décidé après
la diffusion de cette vidéo 2 d'arrêter
sa compagne sa campagne et non pas sa
compagne et évidemment ça pose d'un pose
évidemment énormément de problèmes le
premier c'est d'ailleurs un problème
politique c'est à dire est ce que quand
on est victime d'une attaque pareil il
faut céder ou est-ce qu'il faut résister
genevois problème c'est que quand on est
un politique est ce qu'on doit faire des
vidéos privées des sextapes et les
balancer sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est un peu la vraie question parce
qu'après lui que monsieur mimile qui
aucune importance dans le jeu de la
société face des vidéos pornos qui les
envoie à qui veut c'est pas très grave
mais c'est vrai que quand on fait une
vidéo porno et qu'on les cons la balance
on s'expose à être victime de chantage
alors là c'est un peu gênant quelqu'un
qui a été ministre
alors c'est vrai que normal c'est pas
l'attitude la plus maline maire de paris
c'est le sepa président des états unis
s'est pas non plus bon il était ministre
voilà voilà deux donc ça ça me gêne un
petit peu du déjà on vous dit on
pourrait faire un peu attention que
comme le disait une fois n'est pas
coutume intelligemment lisier fort dès
le président des états unis
quand il est présent détenu on lui
confie ce que c'est tout son matériel il
n'a plus de téléphone personnel il n'a
plus de moyens de communiquer sans
passer par le service baisse s'est
vérifié non mais c'est sur un téléphone
qui est le téléphone sécurisé deledeuil
président et c'est bien lui qui les fait
mais bien sûr n'empêche pas mais c'est
cadré et la bombe et visiblement il ya
quand même certaines amateurisme et
parce que je suis en forme et la vôtre
excusez moi mais une confusion entre
deux choses quand le président des états
unis se sert de ce téléphone dont vous
parlez c'est pour une raison politique
là c'était pas pour des raisons
politiques s'étaient de deux raisons
privées
mickaël landreau dans plusieurs éléments
d'abord depuis effectivement 2007 et la
sphère laure manaudou
moi je me rappelle j'aurais il est
profondément choqué c'était l'une des
toutes premières affaires de nul n'est
censé ignorer que quand on poste une
photo même à titre privé peut se
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
bon ça c'est le premier point est
ensuite - j'ai deux sentiments par
rapport à ça un sentiment de dégoût et
je vais m'expliquer un centime en même
temps de fascination dégoût parce que la
classe politique est quand même censé
incarner une sorte d'idéal une sorte d'
exemplarité et que toutes ces affaires
que ce soit la sphère cahuzac fillon
strauss kahn tron et j'en passe
finalement finissent par celle salir la
classe politique dans sa totalité la des
légitimes et finalement des gens très
bien se retrouvent aussi finalement sous
sous les feux de la rampe alors qu'ils
n'ont rien demandé pour ça et en même
temps donc fascination aussi parce que
si j'essaie de comprendre et de me
mettre à la place des différents
protagonistes de cette histoire mais je
sue c'est complètement incroyable déjà
qu'est ce qui pousse un benjamin
griveaux envoyé une sextape apparemment
à sa maîtresse
qu'est ce qui pousse celle ci à la
communiquer ou alors à son conjoint de
la santé sont à son compagnon de la lui
extirper lundi qu' il a fait ça parce
qu'il déteste poutine et que macron
serai un président importe quoi on est
complètement incroyable et un
emballement médiatique
oui une espèce de dégoût de fascination
en même temps alors voilà mais il ne
faut pas tout mélanger puisque vous
dites qu'est ce qui pousse aux revolvers
tout le monde a le droit de se
photographier en faisant ce qu'on veut
le précédent ministre on l'est pas mais
ça n'a rien de commun avec strauss kahn
qui coince une femme de ménage dans un
hôtel et la morale quand un ministre se
retrouve exilé comme ça sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce qu'on parle des endroits
des choqué hier l'ailier puis ce qui est
étonnant c'est que c'est qu on assista à
deux choses et deux éléments et georges
ans a surpris sur pas mal fameux de cela
le premier c'est que c'est l'explosion
des secrets d'alcôve donc là c'est la
vie publique qui à travers les réseaux
sociaux atterri sur se maintenant sur ce
tribunal populaire elle se trouve
tribunal de tous les instants et puis
c'est 7 ce qui va avec c'est cette
instantanéité et 7,7 transmission de
ceux de ses vidéos privées qui verse
dans le domaine public
on est tous d'accord pour dire que d'une
part c'est pas le premier politique à se
faire
à se faire prendre dans une histoire de
moeurs et de d'esprit volage on va dire
sauf qu'à l'époque il n'y avait on a
tous au moins un exemple il n'y avait
pas ce livre c'est que ces moyens là et
ça reste et ça reste évidemment secret
et est suspect à vous avez du second
degré une photo qui est dans les drire
c'est chirac et mitterrand qui
rigolaient qui rigolent en train de
rigoler et ont des liens de l'adjointe
de six viennent d'apprendre que gribouva
mode d'abord donné une élection parce
qu'il avait trouvé sa fable c'est qu'à
l'époque c'était si c'était même c'était
je suis connue dans un sérail oui mais
là et puis même les français devront
soit pas si mal que ça c'était même
plutôt bien vu voilà sur la page google
doit faire de lui un peu con quoi mais
les franchouillards et puis bon il est
joli mais ça c'est ça une organisation
qui est là on est on est même pas à
l'état de d'étudier les programmes de
chacun des candidats à la mairie de
paris que on en a versé sur le plan
totalement personnelle privée en dessous
de la ceinture
ça pose un certain nombre de questions
sur sur justement ce que l'on sur le
nouveau prêtre que l'on prête à la vie
politique et à la représentation de nos
édiles et et d'une manière générale à la
vie publique et à la vie politique
on est également tous d'accord je pense
pour pouvoir dire que qu'il n'a pas été
très malin de deux tournées et de
diffuser à la base sur les sur les sur
les réseaux sociaux ou même sur internet
avec la toute puissance de google une
photo ou une vidéo peut très vite sur
feu se retrouver sur internet là en plus
il ya un acte anodin
on partage avec des gros guillemets qui
fait que ce risque là de nous de ne pas
avoir fait fait table rase de son passé
alors peut-être diffuser au cirque à b
ou écoutez je pense que plein de choses
ont été dites moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord aussi avec ce qu'avait exprimé
olivier faure sur france inter où il
disait que il avait commis une faute
politique
en envoyant cette photo à son ami alors
il fait ce qu'il veut effectivement de
sa vie privée
6 ou de politique parce que là c'est
pour moi je pense que c'est une faute
professionnelle
dès lors ils y seraient ils seraient
comme
m monsieur michu au bout d'un pardon
jean-charles non c'est moi qui suce à
pose pas de problème mais il est extrait
bini sa vie n'est pas en danger ce
gouvernement dans ses mémoires c'est que
m il se met à aller demain de personnes
qui veulent faire chanter qui veulent le
pop quoi tu sois ici sur ces 10 % béni
pour essayer de déstabiliser
est ce quelqu'un d'ailleurs de
déstabiliser de déstabiliser l'état donc
c'est là où je trouve qu'il a fait une
faute professionnelle qui est pas une
faute pénale
c'est une faute professionnelle dans le
cadre de l'exercice de son activité pas
se méfier des feuilles celle-ci des
procès après enfin c'est souvent lié à
un procès de thierry gaubert
actuellement enfin bon si l'essai était
mieux comportés avec ce qui fera dire
juste mais qu'ils quittaient le rayon
bistouquette en se disant bon heureux au
delà de tout ça il ya quand même des
gens qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce que
ça révèle ça révèle quand même que pour
descendre un type qui se présente à la
mairie de paris qui avait certes pas
beaucoup de bibelots coup de chance
d'arriver à décrocher le trône mais on
va quand même assez loin donc parce que
c'est assez compliquée techniquement
d'avoir piraté la vidéo facile et sûre
snap tchatche ça disparaît très vite
c'est pas le premier crétin est pas
capable de le faire donc il ya quand
même une organisation visiblement
derrière pas des gens bien organisés
pour faire ça et peut-être que s'il
n'avait pas trouvé cette histoire de de
masturbation il devrait trouver autre
chose ça veut dire que vraiment il ya
des gens qui sont là et qui se disent ok
on va faire chanter c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est toi dossier alors là
c'est un dossier sexuelle mais ça
pourrait être un dossier financier ça
pourrait plein de choses c'est ça qui
est intéressant est angoissant j'allais
juste complété parce que là on parle des
politiques mais ce genre d'affaires mme
j'ai eu des dossiers comme ça de trois
dossiers ou des chefs d'entreprise sont
retrouvés dans des situations très
embarrassante parce qu'ils ont eu des
relations avec
une personne de l'entreprise et qui a
fait effectivement du revenge est
derrière n'ont qu'à balancer les vidéos
sur le site intranet delà de la société
et notamment il y en avait un qui était
président d'une société qui était une
société américaine avec une filiale en
france va les américains n'ont pas aimé
ils ont pas aidés et donc c'est pour
dire que les politiques soient
inconscients mais certains aussi chef
d'entreprise se retrouve pris
complètement au piège mouche crois que
les gens moment donné ils se rendent
plus compte de ce qu'ils font et comme
les conséquences de ce four le sexe
comme ça tu fais presque d'euros mieux
pensés avec sa tête qu'avec autre chose
j'aime répliqué le type d'écouteurs sur
cette histoire
et finalement on efface finalement une
une mutation de la société qui est
incroyable j'ai exhumé un sondage
réalisé en 2013 par l'ifop sur les
français la sexualité et les moyens
techniques d'aujourd'hui et en 2013 il
trouvait que les moins de 30 ans une
personne sur quatre avait déjà demandé
une vidéo de son partenaire nu une
personne qui en avait déjà envoyé une
elle-même une personne sur quatre des
moins de 30 ans royan donc c'est
absolument incroyable
enfin je veux dire on est face à une
délation à une diffusion de sondages les
sondages c'est la vôtre vécue autrement
un soulagement un sondage montre que 30
% des français approuvent la diffusion
de cette vidéo
cc c'est 30 % des gens qu'on jamais vu
non plus peut être activée
de conduite je peux m'exprimer ainsi de
deux plans ski qui a mis en ligne ces
vidéos 3d en vidéo sur son site porno
politique et qu'il qu'il dit au départ
c'est pour dénoncer le puritanisme de
certains de nos politiques parce qu'il
n'ya pas que griveaux qui étaient visées
sur ce site
david y en avait plusieurs qui avec
avait des casseroles et donc sombre son
parti est de dire que en montrant ce
type de vidéos il dénonce le puritanisme
affiché d'un benjamin griveaux par
exemple et jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est s était il mettait en avant
beaucoup sa famille ses enfants du monde
mais le débat agité de journalisme
depuis depuis très longtemps il ya eu
des des candidats à la présidence de la
république qui mettait en avant leurs
familles qui trompait allègrement leurs
femmes et je me suis dit jean françois
kahn enfin des djs comme ça qu'ils sont
des journées sérieux et s'était
interrogé est-ce qu'il faut dire les
choses ou pas dire les choses et enfin
la frontière entre la vie privée et la
vie publique
quand est ce qu'elle est c'est
n'outrepasse qu'elle ait aucun il ya eu
aucun démenti ils ont sonné par mois sur
la vidéo il aurait dit non c'est
pourquoi je disais ce qu'il n'aurait pas
dû résister parce que et puis réduit on
aurait pu dire c'est que c'est une
relation extraconjugale peut-être
d'autres vidéos où là il pourrait pas
dire c'est pas moi qui fait des sondages
pour la mairie de paris et ce qu'il
devrait démissionner si vite c'est la
question du sud vous êtes bonne question
finalement il n'a pas profité de cet
énorme coup là c'est peut-être en
parlais tout à l'heure parce que ça
change des situations honnêtement la la
il est totalement détruit il anéantit il
a perdu sa femme l'a perdue fenniche
perdu donc
je pense que changer rien de ma famille
non mais est-ce que vous êtes commande
par acquis par la situation de la
démocratie aujourd'hui jusqu'à moi ce
qui m'étonne quand même si c'est que ce
pseudo artistes russes fassent qu'on
voit sur les réseaux sociaux enfin entre
deux vidéos de cette petite mais on est
pas si sûr que ça ennuie
quand même entre entouré de deux types
qui ont l'air d'être plutôt des fins le
crâne rasé et c'est devant un drapeau
nazi
on le voit brûler essayé de brûler un
mur de la banque de france à paris et ce
type est là en toute impunité les restos
des gens intéressants a donné sa réalité
politique lorsqu un réfugié politique
peut essayer de brûler la porte de la
banque de france et tout le monde dit
bon on sait où ils habitent tous à uche
armand etc
je trouve que la somme sans parler de
laxisme il ya quand même des choses
curieuses en france comme enfin couteau
mais c'est clair que dès qu'on est dans
une dictature et ses dictatures
sympathique post mais franchement on
peut faire faire baisser mais il
évoquera ses aux crises quand même non
ce genre d'affaires français on sait de
l'épreuve durant interrompt le symbole
de la république et de la démocratie
être être mises à mal que ce soit par
les gilet jaune avec des actes très
symbolique comme les statues qui sont
vandalisés à l'arc de triomphe
on a vu aussi la place de république
avait été vandalisée par différents
mouvements
enfin il ya toute une symbolique de
cette démocratie qui aujourd'hui est
attaqué et finalement est ce que la
démocratie se défend moi c'est un peu la
question que je me pose et on a
l'impression qu'elle prend les coups
cette démocratie c'est république et
finalement elle est un peu exsangue et
là un peu atone et moi je m'étonne
justement que la classe politique ne
prennent pas à bras le corps ces
différents éléments et se laisse bafouée
comme ça est ce que la défense de la
démocratie justement ça va pas été dire
c'est une histoire privée ça ne regarde
absolument personne et je maintiens ma
candidature est ce que ce n'était pas
une façon de défendre aussi de résister
vous faudra ces attaques alors il ya une
autre source qui est assez intéressant
me semble-t-il c'est la violence en
politique parce que c'est une c'est un
symbole de la violence en politique
cette attaque sa diffusion des images
mais il semble quand même alors il ya eu
les idées joue
nier des violences dans la rue mais dans
le vocabulaire politique des gens comme
mélenchon com com com comme marine le
pen mélenchon il avait théorisé cette
violence de la scène politique en
pensant peut-être que le fait de m'en
tenir un discours qui s'appropriait
cette violence avait dérivé cette
violence or au lieu de 7 pourrait se
produire ça lâche et d'aider les vannes
à vous avez tout à fait raison mais il
ya un tout petit contre exemple c'est
que l'ajustement sur griveaux à lui donc
de tout l'arsenal hippolyte et de spring
blanchon tout le monde l'a soutenu
toutes façons diverses vidéos sujet
s'attend à des dossiers sa d'unsa d'une
part et ce qui est assez amusant c'est
que je j'ai du mal à imaginer si c'était
un type du front national ou un type
d'un autre bord politique extrémiste qui
s'était fait piéger avec cette vidéo est
ce que l'unanimité politique pour le
défendre et elle a même je pense suis
pas sûr non c'est l'arrivée du général
monde disons est ce que tous les coups
sont permis d or et dans notre
démocratie est ce que dans notre vie
politique et est ce que est ce que tous
les coups sont permis quand on voit une
bassesse comme celle là certes il y a
sûrement eu négligence et bêtise au
départ mais il mérite pas cette mise au
bond et cette mise au pilori populaire
via les réseaux sociaux et très
inquiétants pour l'état du débat au
moins au moins ça l'état du débat dans
la vie politique
ce soit pour des élections municipales
ou des élections d'un autre d'un autre
rang des élections
les cff peuvent quand même pour leurs
espoirs sur lui sur le niveau le niveau
des débats on n'a même pas encore parler
de programme pour tous les candidats
méritent pas mais il faut noter ce coup
bas n'est même pas du monde politique
contrairement aux états unis où les
partis se font des coups terry décès des
partis qui financent parfois déjà sans
se déliter qui profite le crime dans ce
cas là parce que oui à qui profite le
crime
ils étaient pas il n'était pas en tête
des sondages loin de là donc on peut on
peut présumer que ça ne vient pas du
monde politique y aurait eu intérêt à
lemaitre n'a pas besoin de maîtrise
parce qu'en fait le crime profite à la
république grand marche pas que parce qu
il était de vider les corps sur l'effet
de corps ils n'étaient pas bons dans les
semences et permettait de conséquences
politiques sur la balle et de paris il
ya aussi il ya aussi comme internet
enfin derrière tout ça il ya aussi
l'oeuvre à l'émergence des réseaux
sociaux qui a considérablement changé et
nos vies et la façon de faire de la
politique
wen et comment ça se passe en france ma
connexion sur le est-ce qu'on peut
poursuivre les réseaux sociaux est ce
qu'ils ont eux mêmes est ce qu ils
peuvent arrêter de nous les poursuivons
pelé poursuivre que ils ont une
responsabilité si il n'arrête pas un
contenu illicite alors qu'ils ont été
informés de l'existence de ce contenu
d'ailleurs si on leur dit attention il
ya quelque chose qu'il faut supprimer
ils ont 24 heures pour le supprimer
s'ils ne le font pas ils engagent leur
responsabilité et ça s'arrête là
ski seulement rajouter c'est qu'en
matière de sextape
vidéo c'est que ces compagnies là ils
doivent justifier d'avoir mis en place
des moyens pour permettre aux
internautes de faire des alertes
d'accord mais leurs responsabilités
parce qu'ils sont hébergeurs seulement
ils sont pas isolés sont simplement
hébergeurs leurs responsables leurs
responsabilités ça d'ailleurs le site de
plus de profits ce qui a été chanté mais
bon ça va même jusqu'au jusqu'au profil
linkedin de d'alexandra de taddeo qui
est a priori d'encre espagne résumé
compagne de poprad peu avant ce qui est
la dessinatrice et des vidéos dont l'un
l'autre
ça fait beaucoup de beaucoup de spots
aise mais son compte linkedin a été a
été chanté un également assez rapidement
tout à fait mais après faut pas oublier
que même au delà des réseaux sociaux une
fois que c'est parti sur eux sur les
réseaux sociaux
tout le monde sait change des trucs par
mail et là c'est plus voilà c'est même
plus les réseaux sociaux c'est à dire
que on a la vidéo de grimaud tiens si
rigolo et je t'envoie ça et sa part et
la cdc fini hélas aucun réseau social et
derrière c'est juste un échange de mails
et puis c'est oui mais après derrière
s'il ya une diffusion ses mails à chaque
personne alors chaque les personnes qui
rentrent 8 ou des personnes qui
transfère peuvent être pénalement
poursuivi devant elias ont forgé le
dispute à l'heure et arrêter les auteurs
ont validé leurs temps alexandre qui
s'est d'ailleurs
si tous les sens les alpes a déposé par
la députée du lissage arrête tu songes
et s'est élevée de lille lors landat du
niveau là c'est un m je sais pas mais
finalement ce sont les états qui
redescend ce qui bien entendu cette
déclaration de candidature la fusion de
passer sinon ce qui revient à ce qu'il
revient souvent à quatre se sont forgés
cesser pour les détracteurs de notre
équipe gouvernementale en place et de la
lru mc le côté amateur et le côté peu de
recul historique en politique est donc
une équipe qui se distingue par fois par
son par son jugement à l'emporte-pièce
et son avantage avec le suédois school a
été complètement amateur je suis tout à
fait d'accord à gober c'est une solution
ce qui peut aussi réhabiliter la
politique alors oui on a ouvert la porte
à la société civile
on a ouvert la porte a plein de jambe à
cause de la sorte
peut-être que le nouveau l'ancien monde
c'est pas si mal que ça peut-être que
des gens qui vraiment bien la politique
faut dire que ça se fait tout de suite
le discours de ben à croquer version des
députés qu'il a envie d'y rester en
hauteur c'est pourquoi les pays il ya
aussi d'autres débats je suis pas sur 20
vous avez ici sont bien dans le sujet
l'américanisation de la vie politique
est ce que c'est ça ou coup convoi et
puis la question de l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux
là il se trouve que le type est pas un
hymne du tout donc c'est à questionner
d'enigma est-ce que c'est aussi une
américanisation l'américanisation de la
vie politique c'est c'est la morale qui
qui qui est interdit dans le petit
classe et une attaque purement politique
me semble-t-il non moi j'ai l'impression
que ce qui marque la politique
américaine c'est à la fois d'énormes
moyens financiers des moyens
d'investigation des moyens médiatiques
d'un côté et effectivement de l'autre
côté une sorte de puritanisme et il ya
une espèce de patchwork qui se fait
entre ces deux composantes en france
l'aspect financier a quand même été
limités avec les lois qui ont été passés
à la fin du célibat dernier le côté
puritains je suis pas convaincu on est
quand même le pays qui avons fait de
mariage pour tous
je crois qu'on est surtout dans une dans
une perte de frontière entre le public
et le privé est de voir tous les niveaux
et qu'il n'ya plus de frontière et qui
évidemment ces hommes publics s'expose
évidemment et lorsque la frontière
n'existe plus il ya plus de garde-fous
et je crois que ça s'est lancé dans tous
les domaines et c'est de la
problématique des réseaux sociaux et
d'internet et on est vraiment là dessus
ce qui fait qu'il ya plus de privé il
fait beau utiliser un mot anglais dans
le temps de griveaux gates
il ya uniquement le la vitesse de
propagation en fait qui est acquis et à
impulser qui est à imputer aux réseaux
sociaux
mais césar la première la première le
premier geste c'est un premier c'est un
geste maladroit malhabile une connerie
monumentale de griveaux d'envoyer
d'envoyer cette vidéo après le tribunal
populaire et l'explosion du soca
d'alcôve cesser les réseaux sociaux qui
se chargent de propane et de propager
cette cette nouvelle à une vitesse une
vitesse phénoménale absolument
l'anonymat c'est autre chose c'est aussi
un autre problème il est pas en cause il
c'est un vrai problème celui de
l'anonymat c'est vrai que il ya un
déversoir de haine dans
sur qui facilite et probablement par le
fait que je sais pas d'où ça vient mais
c'est pas c'est pas aux pour le coup
c'est parce qu'ils t'ont cause dans
cette affaire
je dis ça parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé
j'aimerais bien que vous ayez raison
mais j'ai l'impression que les sur les
réseaux sociaux les gens sont pas si
anonyme que ça c'est ça le drame c'est à
dire que ce déversement de haine en
commun oui mais bien sûr mais ce
déversement de haine très souvent il est
également le problème aussi
après l'anonymat ben oui il veut moi
très très honnêtement c'est un peu comme
les caméras dans les rues vous ai rien à
me reprocher c'est d'une connerie j'ai
envie que ce soit sous mon nom et voilà
donc moins de l'image plutôt contre mais
voilà sur 13 sur le courage d'assumer
certains propos et ont parlé lors de la
dernière édition de la ferme il a c'est
ce que ceux qui ceux qui attaquent à
visage couvert ne montre pas vraiment de
grand courage d'assumer dans leurs
opinions alors sur ce sur ce sujet là
d'autres choses à rajouter où on peut
passer aux conséquences politiques parce
que ces raisons que va devenir gré ou
pour l'instant est ce que l'esprit d'un
des rennais est ce qu'on peut se
reconstruire
mais ce qu'on peut revenir après ça j'ai
pas politiquement oui c'est compliqué
non bat pas pour le moment ce que le
temps fait ça va être intéressant de
voir comment elles effectivement à ce
que ce que les gens ont une certaine
partie de lectorat quel électorat
quelques lequel jean brondi au bon sens
cheyrou blier ça c'est sûr et le premier
tour a priori après il aurait pu jouer
les victimes et peut-être mais ils
étaient ils étaient touchants en moins
c'est touchant moi je les trouvais
j'aurais aimé le voir un peu plus
combatifs quoi
il est un peu à sa place j'aurais
peut-être est désormais dans le même
état mais je crois qu'il doit être
affecté comme bien sûr la mescaline ce
qu'on attend aussi d'un leader d'un
homme politique de quelqu'un qui aspire
à être au premier rang c'est d'être
d'avoir un comportement probablement
hors du commun et donc peut-être d'être
là en train de dire ben je le battrai tu
sais c'est un qui nous fait ça ok
super j'ai démissionné parce que mes
d'être très combatif et rend là ils
avaient vraiment l'air un peu un peu
souvenir de l'aigle ce jour que je le
prendrai bien mais d'un homme politique
de premier plan on attend peut-être
autre chose et par exemple carlos ghosn
ça n'a rien à voir mais quand il estoit
il est en fuite il se retrouve au liban
il a quand même un des trois camions de
casseroles derrière lui il est hyper
combatif il n'est pas soumis
mais je vais me battre et c'est la
différence est que cardozo pas eu le
temps d'y réfléchir
alors que lui il écrit tout de suite
voilà tout à fait la même affaire non
c'est pas la même merde parce que dira
le côté combatif il ya un moment il ya
un niveau de responsabilité et de est-ce
que ça a touché et fillon d'avoir
persévéré et d'avoir maintenu sa
campagne fait demain je suis pas
convaincu que ces services fillon la
république ou la démocratie où l'image
du politique
la crédibilité il aurait peut-être mieux
fait fillon de brice et courage de
démissionner d'arrêter de dire on l'a
réglé mon problème d'avoir démissionné
je lui reproche un petit peu d'avoir été
un peu un peu trop abattu qu'on aurait
aimé un peu un guerrier voilà dans les
conséquences politiques s'arrêtent vous
sari ou également présenté des monnaies
trempette ça lui permet de sortir je
peux pas et je peux pas dire par une
sortie honorable c'est pas possible
c'est pas sur ses pas sur ces éléments
là bien sûr ça use ça fait une
ça opère une redistribution des 115 ans
on reparle même éventuellement d'une
convergence entre la nouvelle liste d
agnès buzyn et de et deviennent amis qui
redevenait qui reviendrait en grâce chez
chez les oem donc sassareu distress
petit posé derrière les deux premières
il était mal barré
oui très très mal parti et là vous
accompagne pour n'ai pas l'impression
quand même tout le monde se lever le
matin disant tir j'ai une nouvelle idée
claire de la situation mais donner cent
mille euros
un appartement fin donc des idées un peu
bizarre et pas très pensée semble-t-il
là on a une candidate qui après on peut
on peut avoir aimé ou mal aimé ce
qu'elle a fait commises et la santé
enfin c'était une des ministres y en a
deux ou trois qui sont kia blanquet réel
qui dont on parlera comme d'habitude et
mentalement je suis très choquée que est
ce que vous êtes choqué qu'elle a
abandonné par exemple le son ministère
en pleine grillé plein crise de
l'hôpital en prêt une crise du grenat
virus je trouve qu'elle avait sûrement
d'autres priorités il s'est réveillé
j'ai d'ailleurs le jeudi à peu près
qu'elle ne pourrait pas faire campagne
parce qu'elle avait des dossiers où je
suis restée ça absolument incroyable
qu'elle soit débauché de son de son
poste alors qu'il ya des sujets qu'il ya
des sujets brûlants dans son ministère
je voudrais juste préciser une chose
c'est que tout le monde l'attaquant dix
ans le jeudi ou le vendredi précédent
elle a dit qu'elle n'avait pas le temps
elles n'avaient pas le temps de militer
auprès de benjamin griveaux andy bean
c'est complètement différent et en mini
crise ne pas avoir le temps en temps me
dit c'est complètement différent de dire
j'abandonne et je deviens candidement
que dans un premier temps lui avait
demandé d'être on l'avait demandé d'être
candidate aux européennes
je pense qu'on l'avait demandé pour la
mairie de paris elle avait refusé aussi
le préféré ce ministre-là elles vivent
en mission commandée fins si l'on se
suicide même ce qui est bizarre c'est
une chambre et c'est une parisienne une
vraie parisienne auquel elle a au moins
deux avantages dans la campagne actuelle
donc on peut espérer sextape de sa
ça c'était un ordre divin tranquille je
vois la joie love ou alors là on s'est
toujours qu'elle abandonnait mais juste
en mission commandée et mission commando
elle peut avoir quelques elle peut avoir
quelques câbles et où fera courir les
élections se jouent souvent au dernier
moment mais que là y'avait il me semble
je ne sais pas dans la situation
parisienne d'une sorte d' incertitudes
il ya quand même 60 % des gens qui ne
veulent pas la réélection de madame
hidalgo qui cherchent une alternative
qu'il ne trouvait pas s'il ya des
rachida dati qui est monté mais est-ce
que auprès des bêtes mais enfin auprès
de la bourgeoisie est ce que ça ne
fonctionne pas à percer quelques rachida
dati par exemple ah bah oui oui
messieurs je le trouve qu'elle est tout
à fait d'abord elle n'a pas l'argent
peut-être que ça va sortir là on a une à
quatre semaines avant les élections et
il ya peut-être plein de dossiers qui
vont sortir on peut penser qu'il serait
sortie peut-être précédemment côté les
tennis delà de la santé c'est quelqu'un
qui a l'air tout à fait clair et je
crois que voilà je pense qu'on va lui
reprocher grand chose visiblement donc
elle peut il ya sûrement une magnifique
carte à jouer effectivement vous me
disiez plus c'est une femme donc c'est
ce qui est plutôt assez habile
après faut rappeler que ça se joue
arrondissement pendant dix mois n'a pu
être élu
on peut être élu avec moins de voix que
son adversaire que et que probablement
ça va se jouer peut-être entre les deux
tours cette élection en fonction des des
alliances et celles qui seront passés
entre les deux tours donc c'est assez
compliqué siècle les sauvages qu'on a
aujourd'hui devenu jamais dire grand
chose enfin les des sondages puisque il
faut rappeler que deux années d'algos a
été élu avec moins de voix que date et
nicosie aux comores idée si on avait là
mais elle avait gagné les
arrondissements qui comptait comme 30
pause et si c'était ça parce que les
élections des arrondissements
je ne râle pas contre les algues aussi
bien déduction de trois prochains à
quelqu'un d'être élu après après le
système je me la mets pas une chose
encore une femme maire de paris ne
voulait ni pour vous c'est mort trois
quatre fois soumise vous parlais tout à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux des photos
il y avait un truc c'est mans il y avait
20 pour les élections il ya busin bus
deux bus 3 6 millions peut-être une
plainte alors ce n'est pas une
conclusion à ce débat mais il ya un
livre que vous avez beaucoup aimé oui
qui se paie que l'histoire universelle
de la connerie
absolument d'abord elle à skis et alors
c'est pas c'est pas mais c'est pas des
rigolos qui font ce rival à l'université
il pas dire ex et des grands
spécialistes de chaque de chaque domaine
de chaque discipline et qui se demandent
dans leur discipline
est-ce que scoop d'abord est ce qu'on
peut faire une histoire universelle de
la connerie
alors effectivement c'est un livre qui
est sorti à la fin de l'année 2019 qui
est un recueil de
trentaine d'articles qui sont
exclusivement rédigés par des historiens
des spécialistes de sa prise d'acte en
moyenne actuellement et s'est donc
dirigé par jean-françois marmion qui
philosophe et qui a déjà écrit la
psychologie de la connerie déjà il ya en
c'est tout à fait un spécial et de la
delà de la chronologie la chronologie
voilà c'est tout à fait ça donc c'est
pas un bêtisier du tout c'est vraiment
une étude très argumentée et qui
traverse qui traverse les siècles qui
traversent les pays qui traversent les
langues qui traverse les cultures et qui
essaye de faire ressortir quels sont les
conneries accumulées par les hommes au
travers au travers des siècles et au
travers des pays et ce qui est
extrêmement extrêmement intéressant
alors on l'a donné une interview dans le
monde qui était aussi assez intéressante
on lui disait mais quels sont les traits
universel oui pour retrouver qu'il ya
d'universités de la connerie
alors il est dit oui il est très
universel qui ont traversé les âges
c'est la démesure de l'homme le bri
voilà le maïs l'arrogance qui fait
croire que l'on peut être tout puissant
donc qui permet aux cellules en rapport
avec le voilà et en fait il donne une
définition de la connerie qui je trouve
tout à fait excellentes c'est celui qui
juge sans savoir et surtout sans se
soucier de savoir donc ils jugent il
sait pas ce qu'ils jugent mais surtout
ça m'intéresse pas de savoir s'ils
jugent bien ou pas bien quel est le quel
est le problème
et finalement c'est dangereux comme
définition parce que la démocratie
semblait parfois un peu à droite
et on est sans cesse et finalement le le
conte c'est celui qui a des certitudes
celui qui n'a jamais de doute qui se
pose pas de questions il a des
certitudes et puis il y va et jamais il
remet en cause ses certitudes en
l'intelligence c'est peut-être justement
de pouvoir changer changer d'avis et
pouvoir d'évoluer pouvoir évoluer et je
me regarde pas quand vous dites moi
j'accepte ça c'est ceux qui n'ont pas de
certitude et la fatigue mais c'est pas
parce que l'on sait qu'on est un sachant
que pour autant on n'est pas forcément
oui certes mais s'il a la connaissance
faisait qu' on n'était pas content dans
ce cas là les nains et les estampes et
irl et les gens intelligents et pas les
cons donc ça c'est que les nanas et la
culture
n'empêche pas donc ça n'empêche pas des
et donc lui il expliqué finalement le
remède à la connerie c'est le doute
la nuance la prudence la tolérance
ils sont mûrs capacité à changer et
l'autodérision sont visibles pour que
les sommes non mais c'est ce que
j'explique mon travail est assez
intéressante aussi ou sur ce qui est une
énigme pour les linguistes c'est
pourquoi le même mot qui avait une très
belle chanson de brassens là-dessus
désigne à la fois le conte et de sexe
féminin et essayer non personne ne sait
pourquoi
c'est un vaste débat sur le temps
pourrait en parler longuement paix mais
parce que en effet on propose aller voir
des langues indo européenne etc
rien n'est très satisfait au khroub
explications non c'est très intéressant
mais parce que souvent la scène oui
c'est une décision un peu intellectuel
il faut douter pour battre contre ce
temps mais souvent le conte c'est
l'autre quelque part oui y arriver y est
muté dans un autre et un ce qui est
intéressant sur la sur le lien entre la
sphère griveaux et la connerie c'est que
il écrit dans son dans son article qui
est sorti ce week-end mais qui
finalement n'était pas rattaché à
griveaux ils disaient les technologies
d'aujourd'hui procure à la connerie des
bottes de sept lieues et c'est
exactement ce qui arrive
cariat ce qu'on disait toujours c'est
qu'avant toutes les conneries qu'elle
est sûre et sur les réseaux sociaux
c'était au café du commerce et puis
déconfite et des coûts quitté le bar
c'était fini alors que là ça prend une
dimension
la place était déformé avec le téléphone
arabe fait news avec l'édile fait avec
l'image l'image et est resté un petit
peton jusqu'à ce que ça soit coupée et
ça s'est propagé
mais au delà des faut vraiment que la
police ait saisi le procureur aurait
ouvert une enquête mais il faut vraiment
appliqué il ya des articles spécifiques
là dessus il faut les appliquer pas en
venir juste deux minutes 1 l affaire
évoquée qu'est ce qui risque le
l'artiste le pseudo artistes russes
jusqu'à 2 ans d'emprisonnement
c'est l'article est un peu d'argent et
60000 heureux c'est l'article de vence
200 26-2-1 et c'est de pousser en
matière justement de diffusion d'image
sexuelle borno et c'est donc assez
spécifique puisque sa double la peine
d'emprisonnement et il vise bien le fait
que quand quelqu'un fait une photo de
typiquement griveaux fait une photo de
lui même qu'il soit une photo sexuels
qu'il envoie quelqu'un à titre privé dès
lors que sa part sans son consentement
sur les réseaux sociaux ou ailleurs
d'ailleurs peu importe à ce moment là
c'est puni de deux ans d'emprisonnement
et 60 de mémoire 60000 euros damende
donc il faut qu'ils aient un nom qu'on
sent pas la division ce qui est une
évolution législative par rapport à la
jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
jusqu'en 2016 et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
eu cette réforme du code la cour de
cassation 10 à partir du moment où on a
accepté de se faire photographier cissé
publié 6 et publié basse et en plus pour
nous même si on n'est pas consentant
donc là il y avait un arrêt de cour de
cassation mars 2000
16 et du coup derrière ils ont embrayé
pour mettre un article pour bloquer
c'était quand même assez injuste si
quelqu'un accepte de se faire prendre en
photo il n'existe pas pour se retrouver
je crois énormément énormément de jeunes
femmes faut pas que le jeune femme de
deux jeunes hommes aussi mais qui sont
victimes de revenge porn et c'est
monstrueux c'est un politique
toutes les photos la leur aujourd'hui
c'est notamment les jeunes
quelques rires qui ruine la réputation
de la série entre ces deux défaites
le trucage jeu libéré en français ses
gardes au trucage aux photos lors la
personne n'est même pas responsable de
la photo qu'on a pu prendre et donc
céder son supérieur je disais qu'il y
avait une start up qui avait lancé une
application qui permettait de prendre
quelqu'un en photo et avec cette appli
salam et et ça passait au rayon je crois
et la personne à part était tout nu est
donc sûre on prend une photo de
quelqu'un d'habiller on récupère en fait
une photo de nu mais on peut la coste et
avec florence
oui désarmé mais c'est incroyable
d'avancé entre pareco dit peut-être
envoyer un discours de manuel mettront
sur la laïcité séparatisme et sur les
séparatistes
voilà au déclic communautarisme mais ces
partis ne sais pas le débat oui et donc
le discours du président de la
république sur le sur la laïcité sur le
communautarisme et ce nouveau gou
séparatisme qui n'emploient plus tôt
communautarisme il va d'articles de fond
dessus du vide perdant dans le poids
qu'ils et de communautarisme c'est le
nouveau bal français ben oui nouveau et
ça c'est si nouveau que ça ne sais pas
si nouveau je suis je suis ravi que
forme solide et gilbert fait qu'il n'est
pas suspect de la tuerie d'état pointe
de données du combat là dessus et je
trouve ça très bien mais mes nouveaux
mâles non c'est là il ya des gens qui le
découvrent maintenant enfin
notamment tout une baisse qu'il ait pas
de plus en plus présents au fond c'est à
le réaliser l'impression qu'elle
peut-être le le couvercle que beaucoup
de gens ont voulu mettre sur la marmite
est peut-être en train de s'échapper un
peu que du coup on s'aperçoit vraiment
que ça il ya des gens qui voulaient pas
le voir qu'ils voulaient pas signer les
problèmes qui est nié l'évidence ce en
train de dire bah oui oui quand même
qu'ils vont avouer on en est là mais
c'est dramatique faut dire que je crois
que franz-olivier giesbert en parle dans
son papier mais le bouquin de von den
poupaud ni la qualité extraordinaire qui
lui pendant des années quand même a été
le chantre sauf celles malades vont des
années semblait ne rien voir dans tout
est merveilleux pas d' amalgame pas de
stigmatisation qui va maintenant son
bouquin c'est une bombe atomique enfin
je veux dire je souhaite que tout le
monde glisse jusque là très grand khan
est parmi nous écoutez moi je je je
pense que les mots ont leur importance
c'est vrai que des mots comme
assimilation intégration qu'on a utilisé
pendant des décennies finalement laisse
penser laisse entendre qu'il faudrait
abandonner une partie de ce que l'on
n'est pour se fondre dans la république
ou la nation alors qu'en fait pour moi
le problème n'est pas là le problème
il se commence à se poser lorsque les
lois de la communauté s'oppose aux lois
de la nation de la république par
exemple avec l'excision avec le droit au
blasphème avec la mixité des piscines ou
les piscines
tant qu'il n'y a pas finalement de
collusion entre les règles de la
communauté et les règles nationales n'ya
pas parce qu'on peut se retrouver dans
une communauté sait pas exactement il
n'y a rien de mal dans la communauté par
exemple est ce qu'on entend parler du
poids de problème avec laquelle nous
meute et vietnamienne parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de lois ou de règles qui viennent
s'opposer à aux lois de la république et
je pense que
la république doit être inflexible
lorsqu'on lorsque ces lois sont bafouées
et c'est justement d'aller au d'aller
contre les lois de la république et
c'est là que le problème se pose est
donc je suis content qu'on change de
terminologie parce que moi j'appartiens
divers comme une communauté programmes
jeunesse et ses colorations faisait
l'augmentation est forte et le sentiment
d'appartenance il est très important
dans dans le bien-être et le
développement de chacun et dont je suis
très content concon émigrer vers l'asie
samedi bien ça ça veut dire on est
ailleurs exactement tire sa valise
c'est plus une question de global de
vivre ensemble cette capacité jusqu'à
maintenant est de la société française à
avoir intégré toutes les communautés
toutes les sensibilités et de pouvoir
continuer à le faire sans son sens ont
considéré que que justement c'est que
les lois de la communauté des
communautés prévalent sur le sur les
lois les lois de la république
j'aime assure qu'on ait intégré les
communautés je pense que oui on a plutôt
a mis de côté un certain nombre de
communautés
qui n'ont pas eu ou la mixité qui
existait une certaine époque a été
complètement éclaté et que chaque
communauté est un peu a été parqué un
peu dans des coins et du coup on se
retrouve avec avec des oppositions c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça peut fait
ce qui se passe aux états unis mais sont
la technique et la dignité avec la
théorie république a mené sa marche pas
quoi aux etats unis c'est vrai que dans
les pays anglo saxons général à chaque
communauté vie de quartier avec ses
propres règles pratiquement s agissant
au nom notamment sur l'hybridation un
peu d'avoir sa licence mal maîtrisée
c'est pas notre c'est pas notre histoire
c'est pas nos valeurs nous c'est la
république donc cesser tous dans la même
communauté ici on peut déséquilibrer
il faut aussi de temps en temps enfin
appeler un chat un chat c'est patent
aprem de communautés qu'un problème de
religion c'est clair et net vous 18
heures on n'a pas de problème avec les
vietnamiens oui c'est sûr il ya un
problème avec qui un problème avec
l'islam extrémiste avec une vision de
l'islam rigoriste voilà c'est tout dire
appelons les choses par leur nom
et là le débat peut vraiment avoir lieu
parce que si on continue à dire ah bon
on a pas on n'a aucun problème et que
les coréens du nord on a vu ici c'est
certain
voilà mais avec qui et avec qui est-ce
que ça peut vous un problème
voilà on le sait et et 90% des musulmans
a pas de problème les 10 des problèmes
avec 10 % de musulmans qui ne veulent
pas s'intégrer qui ne souhaite pas
s'intégrer visiblement est le problème
il est là il ya un moment il faut juste
le dire
et après ça n'a rien ni de raciste
hector mais si pendant des années la
gauche n'avait pas essayé de faire taire
toute personne parce que dès qu'on a un
discours en disant ah oui attention
l'islam peut faire peut en dire bah vous
êtes d'où vous êtes d'extrême droite
êtes un fasciste étage donc personne
personne n'ose rien dire mais il faut le
livre de pouponner il faut le livre il
faut le le numéro spécial du point il
faut tout ça pour qu enfin les avocats
sinon qu'on peut parler
qui est retentissant sur les territoires
conquis par l'islande au zouk et les
choses nous reste une minute donc ça vu
la loyale et la soirée des césar va
polanski les des associations féministes
demande de ne pas voter pour j'accuse de
polanski en abu bakr s'occupe de bila
plutôt calme plutôt que de s'occuper de
césar grégoire est libellé les gens qui
l on a droit dans le cinéma sion veut
puis on y va et on y goûte on y va où on
n'y va pas
c'est un excellent film moi je pense
qu'il faut dissocier l'homme de l'oeuvre
d'une manière générale parce que si on
avait assimilé tout au long des siècles
les hommes à leurs oeuvres
on aurait peut-être éliminé jean jacques
rousseau et que ces traités les mille et
d'éducation parce qu'il a mis cinq
enfants
l'assistance publique rai révoltèrent
c'était bien me fichu lui d'ailleurs est
ce qu'on doit éliminer céline parce
qu'il c'est un antisémite par les pareil
pour redire kipling donc je pense qu'il
faut on est suffisamment intelligent je
crois moi je fais considérer de je fais
confiance à l'individu et à la réflexion
de chacun pour être capable d'aller
regarder un film tout en sachant que
l'homme a fait des actes répréhensibles
et que la morale réprouve
hier et florent en deux mots parce que
liberté d'expression pour faire la part
des choses
tout à fait d'accord michael pas mieux
pas mieux et c'est un très bon film
pierre chevalier
mais quelle au boulot et jean-charles
johnny très vite pour un nouveau numéro
de paf
[Musique]